[Music]
anybody else
dear you got near policies
no i haven't received any apologies
except for mark
yeah
um was it changed in the duck i don't
know if ray has has
the same kind of diary as we've got but
does he
i surely hope he hasn't gone to um
oxford
um counselor it was changed in the diary
and i have i don't know
it looks like he's just arriving thank
goodness
okay i because i haven't looked at it in
the last few hours but just even
yesterday it was um
you know just looking at it now um okay
now that's great i'm sure you'd be on to
that to you but i would just had a
terrible thought there for a moment
because we always have rey
i'm glad you're not in oxford ray
you're here good
okay
all right somebody'd like to move we
accept the apology for mark brown please
sarah thank you
here that
he thank you autumn favor
against
jerry thank you
uh public forum we have no public forum
i presume
no mr jefferson we don't
right
conflicts of interest
nothing okay
confirmation of minutes of the office to
the hogan community board 6th of april
somebody move their true record please
thank you wendy segada
right now you're all on fire
against
carrie thank you
know the amputations and presentations
are assumed
all right
mr jefferson you need to go back to
matters arising
oh sorry is there a mata's horizon
i've got one the heck i hope a meadows
pond
ray did you find anything out about that
um no i've looked at the um
drainage map and it appears that they
are on it but the
uh drainage system going through our
hockey meadows isn't part of the council
maintained um
network so i'm not sure whether
um that
has been relayed back to the
uh residents
but um
it doesn't look like the pond that
they're talking about is actually an
issue for um council to maintain
all right thank you
and you've heard the matters arriving
surely
yes um it's just that i
talked on behalf of kidring today at the
uh hearings for the annual plan and i'm
not very happy with the reply well with
the comments that was received
um
evidently the something to do with the
speed limit has to go to cabinet yet if
you read ted's dreams letter that he got
from waka
katahi that the council can can aim for
it that doesn't say they have to put all
those things and
miss
mia gordon actually said he would
arrange for a zoo meeting and i'm
wondering did that happen and i would
really like
an answer that why
is cabinet involved at this stage
through you mr chairperson i've made a
note of that julian i will follow that
up and report back to the board as soon
as possible
thank you dear
any further matters arising
thank you
um just surely um if i may through you
mr chair um just to address that um
it was because in intense in the letter
that ted got back from waka kotahi he um
it said that
currently
they don't require you to put
infrastructure in place to slow down
traffic before you try to change the
limit but they are changing it it hasn't
actually happened yet so that the new
regulations that they're they're
proposing haven't actually happened i
think that's what he was referencing but
you know i'm i'm not um a pro in that
area but that was my understanding as to
what he was talking about with cabinet
but um i i think that's looking actually
pretty positive to be honest
but um yeah does that make more sense
no it doesn't because this has been on
the radar for over seven years
so
it could have been done a long time ago
so that is
my question why
why has it taken this long for it for it
to get to this
my only response to that would be that
they were under the impression that that
was how because they had gotten that
look i'm not going to relitigate this
with you shirley i'm on your side so i'm
just saying that but what the mayor was
actually referring to was in fact
that the new change in legislation has
not yet taken place to our knowledge and
when it does then that will remove that
impediment and then we can go back and
have another bite
so i'm with you i'm on your side it's
okay
all right
we move on to deputation
sorry
shall we move on to deputations or is
there more questions
is there any further matters arising
doesn't appear to be so move on
no deputations presentations no german
business
no report
that's at first
correspondence
dear
thank you mr jefferson through you we
received a
email from the mandeville sports lab as
you may recall
the board granted them
477 dollars for a member's life or life
members board they have now
purchased the board but the two people
who they actually wanted to put on the
board doesn't actually want to go on the
board
because
i don't know why but um they are now
requesting if they could spend the
remainder of the funds
on
engraving a plaque
with these two members names on it
and um
i've spoken to tracy and i've spoken to
k and
i don't see a problem with that because
it's basically for the same thing the
club will just have to be made aware
that if they then at a later date wants
to
inscribe the my life members
board they won't be entitled to any more
funds i don't know what the war's
feeling is
around that
wendy thank you just um
to just bring up on this the the two
people that they wanted to um
put on the the board honors board was um
very instrumental in getting mandible up
and running
but they're both
pretty proud people and they they simply
do not what they said they've been given
enough now and they don't want their
names to go on the honours board so
that's fair enough they don't want to do
that then so this other way of doing um
putting a um
whatever it's called a plaque instead
to go under a tree or something i don't
know what they're going to do with i
think that's what they're going to do
plant a couple of trees
and that's probably that's fine it's up
to the two gentlemen concerned if they
want their name on an honours board or
not and they've said
no but that doesn't mean to say that
honours board won't be used later
because there are other people that that
could go on that board very easily but
they just wanted to respect the two
people that had been involved heavily
involved in it
okay
thank you wendy any other comments
right i believe that we should approve
them
spending their excess money on a flat
somebody'd like to move that
sarah thank you
charlie thank you any further discussion
no all in favor
begins
carried i guess
i will abstain
please
okay
um through you mr chairperson the second
piece of correspondence is just a letter
and respond to the
swara community board submission for the
long term plan
and it was previously
emailed to all the members so this we
just need to receive this
the letter
right
thank you and i've got a couple of
there's a letter from the ohio
residents association thanking the board
for their contribution
of
three thousand dollars i think it was
towards
landscaping and um
finalizing the
[Music]
um
help me out here
the flying fox yes it's 11.
anybody want to put their name down for
an auction for the first ride
and
i see on
uh
email today that the pea gravel and soil
have been delivered and
finish off so
that's a good thing
and there's also a letter from the mayor
regarding submission to the annual plan
which was
in amongst
this
agenda or after the agenda
it's a recommendation that the
correspondents be received please
thank you
please have a bit of discussion about
the response to the long-term plan
please though
yeah over here
yeah
just uh
firstly it's really disappointing that
it's a year late
um
but the the section on the oxford sewer
scheme
doesn't make a lot of sense to me
because they
we've asked for a bit of a breakdown and
costs
um
in our question we asked for how why is
this expensive to run what's proposed
for the substantial depreciation the
council is accumulating
and they they say the total operating
expenditure is approximately nine
hundred thousand
comprising of asset management at one
hundred and twenty eight twenty four
thousand articulation
uh maintenance
and pump maintenance at twenty thousand
there's a fair gap between
nine hundred thousand and those three
figures i would have thought um
yeah i just don't think it's a
a great update and a great response from
council staff to be honest so i was
wondering if we could have a follow-up
on that through your tear
i will
the thing about depreciation
on these assets is that the council is
required by
law
to
retain that depreciation
um
i'm quite not quite sure why that is the
case whereas private business you
don't have to retain depreciation it's
just
part of your book work
so i'm a bit in the dark about that
but they even say like there's 1.9
million of retentions over the 10 years
of the long-term plan it's better to be
accumulated but they've only got plans
to spend one million of that um
and currently there's 375 000 in the in
the um renewals budget so it just sort
of
i don't know just doesn't seem to
make a lot of sense i think there's a
fair bit of information missing to be
honest
generally i thought one of the questions
that we asked was how many how much
money was in the depreciation account
is that the renewals account because if
that's the case
375 000 is not a lot especially when
they said
when we asked once before over two
hundred dollars of each person um that
belongs to the surge was paying over two
hundred dollars
and that's been for quite some time so i
would have expected to be a lot more
than three hundred and seventy five
thousand dollars
doug
yes
there's a difference between renewal
and depreciation depreciation is over
the life of the
the sewer system
so that when it is
for full reaches its life then you've
got amount of money that can replace it
the renewal system is upgrading the work
the the
bits and pieces that need to be upgraded
um
for development of more
more people coming on board
and plus um wear and tear
well then how much is in the
depreciation account that's what we did
ask for
well i can't answer that but that's
something that uh they can they can let
you know yeah
thank you
any further comments on that
i guess we gotta wait for
tia to get an answer for us thank you
chairpersons report
been a fairly quiet month for me
um north canterbury neighbourhood
support has changed their meeting day
from the third
thursday of the month to the first
thursday of the month so there has been
no meeting
last month that we've got one tomorrow
um
i had three
exact
services to attend
um
[Music]
ohioka oxford and west edmond
i felt the our hoka one was the most
comprehensive
and today i presented
answers to any questions on
the board submission of the annual plan
that was my lot
for this month
somebody moved that report be received
please
ray thank you second thomas thank you
all in favor
against
terry thank you
right matters for information items 10.1
to 10.6
10.7 sorry
um
somebody move that these reports these
letters be
accepted thank you charlie check it out
thomas thank you all in favor
against
please ask um andy cocker's yeah
brief the board on the mandible
stockpile
would it could we please um deal with
andy before we go into members
information exchange
if that's okay with the board members
thank you mr chair that's right andy
hello
um just bear with me while i share a
screen i've just done a a very quick
powerpoint presentation just really
highlighting the key areas of where
where we where we where we are where
we're heading um
you will note that i
included you in uh an in a notice for
information that largely talks around
the same thing so hopefully it's a recap
and then
if you have any questions you can uh
fire away at the end uh let me share the
screen
so
i'll move some windows around
right can everybody see what i'm sharing
now
oh this is terrible when you have to
slide all the windows around
okay right
so
works today as you're aware we've been
working through we've had a preliminary
contamination assessment completed and
and as you're aware i think chris brown
presented to you guys in terms of what
those preliminary findings were around
around a bound asbestos found
um in terms of progress for we've gone
from there we've obviously we've had the
the drone survey done to fight to
establish uh
an accurate assessment of the volume
that's now obviously been complete and
we've got a uh roughly just under 3 000
um cubic
meters of material that we've got to to
deal with
we've um
developed our resource consent
application and that's been submitted
and that's been accepted for processing
so that is now in process it's been in
process for the for approximately 10
days
as you may be aware that's a standard
20-day process depending on rfis um the
positive side of that is we haven't had
any rfis to date so that's that's pretty
good news
um i did have some preliminary um
conversations with the consenting team
as well just to sort of head head a lot
of the questions off at the past
um with a
on-site meeting with them
that the planning team and ecam
themselves
he can
in terms of what their their involvement
they are
they're wanting a watching brief um they
are comfortable
with the contamination the preliminary
assessment has identified and that we've
had some negative results on chemicals
and metals within the stockpile
they do want to watching brief just in
case when we continue to do our detailed
site investigation we do find anything
of that type because that may change our
potential methodology
for for total disposal
um resource can in terms of the detailed
site investigation that did start as
planned on friday last week um they've
they've got about 50 of the way through
that
testing on-site testing process
um in terms of a quick pricey of what
they're doing and how they're testing
they are
they've got an excavator on site they
are digging through the center of each
small stockpile across across its length
to effectively individually take samples
out of each stockpile so we can ident
detail this identify
that we've still got
just the bound asbestos
contamination there or potentially
whether we've got anything else that um
we might need to to deal with um the
initial verbal feedback from them is
that it's it's very good it's still
in line with the preliminary assessment
and they are finding some stock piles
that are just clean phil which is which
is good news
um
unfortunately we are slightly
behind that because we
the uh the engineer that's doing the uh
the assessment on site has
tested positive over the weekend
so we are slightly delayed day uh day by
week
but we are intending to get an eta of
sight works complete by the 11th of may
which is the following wednesday um
then it will be taken to
the labs for testing which is
approximately a 10 day turnaround and
then we've got a report and write up an
evaluation back to myself for review
um the result of that
site investigation will will will allow
us to develop the methodology they will
be developed in parallel
so we can try and gain some momentum on
on where we are in terms of disposal
um and
i've agreed with ecan to keep them
informed all the way through that
process um i had a small meeting with
them last week as well they are still
very comfortable with where we are and
really pleased and they have had a
number of um
they've been contacted by a couple of
people within the district asking
questions around it and they've been
reporting directly back to those um
those people that they are they are
comfortable
um after that we expect to receive the
the resource consent approval so
hopefully within a couple of weeks we'll
we'll receive that subject to the rfis
um and and then we will be drafting
reports um for approvals to council in
terms of the next steps
um
in regards to communications um you will
obviously notice that the the notice for
information has gone out um
that when i i deliver that directly to
two members residents on north air road
that had contacted this directly with
concerns
i've had feedback from
all of those people comfortable with
what has been done in terms of the
testing process to date
they will get further updates from me as
soon as the testing process is finished
to confirm and to walk them through the
methodology in terms of disposal to
ensure that everybody is comfortable
with with everything um that's being put
in place and their insurance that that
we're what we're doing is compliant
in terms of the testing everybody was
very comfortable we have um
air testing on all of fences to to
ensure that there's no transmission
across dampening
of the stock pulses as the excavation
occurs um
and
for the board um the the testing results
that's been done on day one um there
were no no registered asbestos um in the
air on monitoring at all so again um
the precautions put in place are working
um the the public health side of of this
uh this issue is is is being controlled
um
i will circulate and may notice
after that testing is done and and then
an update in terms of target
deliverables
um i
know you'll know in the april
notice that i've tried to identify a
placeholder for a public meeting just in
case people
residents are concerned about the
methodology where we get to with that um
that is still probably an intention to
to do it in that way um it will all
depend on what comes out of the testing
and how that methodology develops um in
terms of when that occurs at the moment
i've sort of got a placeholder at the
end of may it's likely due to this
coveted issue that we've got that i
might have to um push that out till
early june um but i will come to um out
to the the main parties involved to
ensure that we've got uh alignment of
dates so everybody can attend with with
a clear agenda in terms of what will be
discussed at that meeting
um
that's pretty much in a nutshell where
we are and in terms of where where what
works we've all done today and and where
we're going to go where we're planning
to go to um
we're
marking a potential um period in terms
of where we can
safely dispose of the material in terms
of when that hits this is all dependent
on council decisions
um but we're looking at sort of
mid mid june to early july to be a point
where we have reached all of our
obligations under the compliance ie
resource contents and um approvals to to
to get the material underway
um but we are in a good position um
obviously we've got the polymer seal on
it it is in a it's in a nice stable
state
um so relatively low risk all the
fencing is there
and we've got a good amount of
vegetation growth over that area now too
which all helps to encapsulate the
material that we've got
so that that that's my presentation
that's the update um i'm open to any
questions anybody may have
yeah that's right
i hope that's unusual
thank you for all of that that sounds
very encouraging
um it looks like all of the residents
who are uh in the near vicinity have
been uh informed
is there any thought of it going out in
the media so that the whole of
mandeville are aware of what's going on
i think we will likely probably send
something out by the comms team um the
notice uh the april notice was uh
effectively prioritized because of my
testing to to expedite the testing the
the
the methodology update in terms of where
we are
is very likely to go out by the comms
team to to the wider wider group
okay
and um
the site itself is it actually inside
the boundary or is it on the road
reserve
it is actually inside
unfortunately it's sitting inside the
boundary of of uh
of the domain
so will it be continued to be a hail
site as far as
environment category are concerned
no it won't
once we get to the point of um
removing what we will be required to do
is is to scrape a further 200 to 300 mil
from the um
from the existing top soil from the
original platform and then we will need
to introduce clean fill and then reseed
um that that's all been
factored into part of my methodology and
my plan um
even before uh liaising with ecan it
that's a pretty standard process
um so effectively we will bring it back
to what it was
okay and
um litigation
uh
processes underway to deal with this
yeah i can't talk too much about it but
i can um provide you the assurances that
um
legal legal the legal process is
underway um it is it is happening and
occurring in the background as well as
an investigation related to
the planning rma breaches with the
planning team
okay thank you andy
duck you unmute
i'm guessing it's my turn
that all right
doug
um
andy i just wanted to ask you just
following on from that last question of
raise because he just about touched on
it um could you please clarify for us
there are there are legal issues at play
here right now could you please clarify
for us what can and cannot be
communicated with the public
well having spoken to the legals our
legal team um
at the moment we are still
the legal teams are all waiting to to to
for some of the third parties to engage
our and whilst that is still occurring
um we cannot compromise the the process
in terms of obviously having
having party or
being going out into the media and and
being communicated to the wider public
um
that is the difficulty at this point in
time um this can be quite a long
protracted process and that's what we've
been told um hence why we are sort of
progressing with with an understanding
of where where we're going to end up in
terms of true cost timelines etc
um
it doesn't necessarily answer your
question nikki sorryly sorry but
i have been sort of assured that that we
really can't go through and talk around
the finer details of it because um it's
likely that it will it will be available
at one point but i think once all
parties are all talking to each other
and and there's some kind of dialogue
going on
all right
thank you for that i just yeah because
there's a lot going on with us and and
all of the community board members will
be
yeah
really important that we all understand
where
we should be standing so that we don't
compromise any of this because we really
want to get the best outcome here and
yeah i suppose if i can jump in in terms
of we've got sort of we've got three
legal representation
we've got council legal representation
representation
mandeville sports club have their own
and and then the planning team in terms
of esu and the enforcement on their rma
have their own so we've got
it
it's quite intricate in terms of how
this has all got to happen in the order
that it's got to happen um
and likewise we're the same in terms of
our we we're we're having to work quite
closely with esu so even our legal
process because we're going to do this
in in in parallel
um doesn't compromise each other in
terms of the ability to to find
liability
and andy so would it be wise then if
anybody gets any queries about this to
direct them to yourself
yes please yes please because then i can
uh unseek the advice from from from our
legal team to ensure that i don't i
don't i don't effectively do something
wrong
all right cool thanks for that
appreciate it
any further
yeah i've got a couple of questions doug
yeah
um hi eddie two quick questions um
firstly as you're going through and
testing these piles obviously the
polymer seal is going to be disturbed
and isn't going to be
there anymore so is that going to be
reapplied at the end of the testing or
what's the plan around that and at this
stage do you have any idea
when the work to start getting rid of it
is going to start
firstly
we will what the plan is is to make
effectively make good and then we will
get pro trans backing to to polymer over
the areas that have been exposed to
again
seal the pile um
and then
in terms of when the plan is i can the
the process if we had uninterrupted
process we could get to the point where
we could start to remove the material in
mid june early july
and that's just that's just a compliance
process element of it
the bit that will will the most all that
will be the decision around the legal
element so we hope that we can get all
of the compliance process we've then got
the legal element up to a point where we
can where council can make a decision
whether to proceed
and remove the material and seek to
claim costs or whether a dialogue is
occurring
that the the the that allows that
mechanism to happen in a different way
does that is that does that actually
yeah that's good thank you and i just
like the comment that the communication
has been a lot better as well so that's
that's another positive as well thank
you
yeah no i've i was um
hence why it was very quick to get to
get something out when we didn't go out
onto the
the comms team facebook pages i i was i
wanted to ensure that if there was an
excavator in that space
that i was front footing that and giving
a good week in advance so i appreciate
everybody sort of grabbing what i sent
out and and then that allowing me to to
go out to those local residents because
they'd been quite keen and
to understand what was going on and
actually had followed up in the interim
too so i really kind of knew that i
needed to to keep them on board and i've
had good responses back from them so i
i'm i'm comfortable that that i can uh
that there's a there's a dialogue
between myself and those local residents
that have been that that have been
really concerned
um and i can continue that now they've
got a they've got a point to come to me
and and and i can keep on top of it
thanks for that
andy is there any comeback on the
contractor that supplied this material
in the first place
that is what um the esu
um and the planning team are looking at
as part of the rma breach um because
they would be involved in terms of the
breaches that
it's all linked to the the original
owner and then the haulish company etc
etc so that's the bit that i don't know
whether we will ever we will i don't
know whether we're going to get to that
um obviously
there is clear breaches
that
occur but i that's the bit that i can't
talk about at this point because i need
to try and allow them to do their work
okay
doug can i just interrupt here for a
moment please look can we just gotta
make really clear here there are two
processes happening there is one that is
about
landowner dealing with the issue
um and taking what um legal advice and
action needs to to resolve the issue of
who did what costs then there's this
other thing that is around from the
planning perspective in terms of were
there breaches of our district plan
rules of um national you know the
national um planning guidance those
rules and regulations that we have
and that's where the planning team are
looking through that they are aligned
but separate processes
um and it's really important from the
compliant when you're talking about
compliance from the investigating any
potential breaches of district plan for
example that that happens very separate
it wouldn't matter if it was council or
anyone else we have our processes that
we go through so we do that
independently of ending the work he is
doing in terms of dealing with the issue
and and
thinking about costs and where do they
fall so that's thus they are separate
processes and of course really important
that they not be chatter chatter and
anything that could compromise any
parties position or understanding
because that is not where we are
currently at that is what is being um
worked through at the moment so it's
it's it's it's in that process so
hopefully that clarifies matters
thank you tracy
any further questions or comments
sarah has a question
sorry tim
sorry i think my questions have pretty
much been answered i guess my question
um the one that maybe hasn't is is it
the
is it the land owners
being the council that go through the re
the resource consent process or is it
the laces that go through the resource
consent process
for disposal
yeah
um it it'll be the it's the land owners
so it's just this council that we need
to to take that through
right okay so
it's
currently it's council's responsibility
as the land owner
to be doing this whole process and at
the end of it whoever is
liable for that cost will be determined
at a later date
correct
right correct
we have a duty of care as a land owner
to to remediate or to make every attempt
to remediate this land
um if
the the the the cost associated with in
the litigation the liability side of it
is is separate now
um in terms of obviously the the the
consent the the resource consent and and
the and ecan they are looking at council
to to to expedite the remediation
because
it is it is on our land
regardless of of the any elise agreement
arrangement with mandeville sports
all right okay
but we are working both we are working
with mandeville and we're we're working
closely with econ and the planning team
so um
we are
personally we are we are we will not
incur any further costs um associated
with with the remedial works without uh
an approval process and council being
being informed
thank you
all right
thank you very much andy it's been very
important thank you
no problem thank you
all right we'll move on to
members information exchange
start in the top left corner with
servers
i've done nothing much
um just attended a museum meeting and
let them know just about that we have
got funding if they've got any projects
other than that
nothing much just hibernating
thomas
thanks doug um yeah no i haven't done a
lot either really to be honest there's
been no actually gorgeous advisory group
meetings there's been no pearson park
advisory group meetings i have had a
couple of people
um email me and give donations to the
ashley gorge advisory group over the
last months which is quite good they've
all had
positive feedback and really enjoying
the walking track um and uh
i think
the native bird life was one of the one
of the compliments and the other one was
the quality of the walking tracks
available
so
yeah that was really good feedback i
think for that group and i folded that
on um
the oxford community trusted a
easter
lot of promotion sort of a
morale building
exercise through that i've got your back
campaign they gave out
uh easter hampers to all of the
businesses and community groups in
oxford with a
just a selection of um easter eggs and
things like that and a card saying
um thank you for the commute from the
community for all the work you've done
over the last couple of months um and
that was really well received they gave
about 35 of those
over the week before easter which was
really good um
and again i think a lot of the business
owners in particular
were really pleased because i don't
think it was but i think it's been a
pretty hard time for
lots of our retail business over the
last couple of months
um
and other than that i attended the
um anzac service at oxford i i saw you
there doug i didn't get a chance to
catch up with you but
um yeah attended that it was quite cold
and quite short i thought but um yeah it
was quite a nice morning for it though
but other than that it's been very quiet
so that's me all right
give that to us i'm sorry i didn't spot
you i was a little disappointed but you
were there so that's good thank you
sarah
uh yeah much the same not a lot has been
happening and here i did
um on friday
do the deportation to eken in regards to
the annual plan
um
so
that's about all i have done
thanks
thank you for that
right
all right
yes i attended the hoka um anzac
ceremony was very moving
well attended by the community
and some
very good
speakers there as well
um
the just an update on the on the
mandible village uh i drove past here
today and i saw that the uh the concrete
pads would be put down for the
um barbecue tables which is very
pleasing to see
the
uh tables i guess will be fixed to the
concrete pads and and due course just a
couple of questions that i have
um
[Music]
just just around the maintenance of that
particular area
i see there used to be rubbish bins
around the
mandible village but they've since been
removed is there any uh
is there any intention of council to
maybe re-establish some rubbish bins
over there because there'll be a lot of
families who'll be having their um
[Music]
fish and chips over there and and you're
taking advantage of
the barbecue tables um and they'll need
somewhere to put their rubbish uh i
guess
if you are able to
make some inquiries there would be would
be great
the mandeville village there's a lot of
activity there on the
eastern side where i did see
several months ago some resource consent
applications
therefore um car parking and
some concept plans for some expansion of
that particular area but i'm just uh
wondering um
which particular plan are they are they
using there because it's very hard to
see from from what's happened so far my
understanding was that it was initially
until the proposed plan was
or the operative plan
the proposed plan became an operative
plan that they were going to wait until
there was a
zone change to be
looking at
introducing further shopping
and then in the meantime in the interim
they were going to be expanding the
car parking i'm just wondering if there
was any um update on what type of car
parking it was whether it was just a
gravel area and uh what size were the
car parks going to be because there's
been an issue that's been uh around the
initial development there where the car
parking has been inadequate for um for
what had been uh developed there that
would be interesting to find out
what um what they're doing
at the moment and uh
the other thing the final thing was the
mandible walkways i've spoken to a
number of residents and a couple of
developers about the
the walkway cycleways most of which lead
to the uh the mandible sports center
and i did a walk around with a couple of
residents the other day
trying to work out what was uh what was
going on there some of them for example
from
rayburn lead quite nicely into the
sports center and have been well thought
out and have been finished off and as as
a really good uh access for the
residents but some of the newer
developments have got uh walkways and
cycleways which seem to go nowhere and
they're either stopped by a fence or by
a drain and what i'd like to
like to do is to maybe spend some time
either with
green space or without planners and have
a look at that overall
walkway concept for mandeville and what
was intended and what we can do about
making the uh
the pedestrian and cycling access around
mandeville um a lot better i've also had
an approach from a few people in
milfield
who um
some own an excess way and uh uh trouble
because people think it's a a council
walkway and others who thought it was a
council walkway and have been told that
no it's not and uh this is this is a
relatively new
uh part of middlefield and it seems
quite logical that people would walk
down this particular space to get to the
mandeville village now that it's there
but it would be really good to to to
meet up with um
council staff and see what the overall
uh concept is for pedestrian and
cycleways around mandeville if that
could be
organized would be
absolutely fantastic
but that's all i've got
thank you ray
councillors
who are we having first
i'll decide wendy
well you've got my little written report
i've just done an update on bits and
pieces that are happening
um council we've been really busy
mainly by zoom
and i did have a dog
classification hearing
last week and
so and it was really quite nice that
we'd go into the the chambers to do that
because there was only a handful of us
there
so i just sort of felt like i was back
in the living land of living again
because it's been just sitting looking
at a screen is not great
for a lot of meetings and actually quite
tiring because i've been long days
so um but no it's we've just been
extremely busy and it'd be lovely some
stage when we'd be allowed to go and
have a talk with the staff again
and that would i'd be really
appreciative of that because that's
something we've badly missed
okay so if anybody's got any question
about anything i've written on my report
there
um
then they can just ask
okay and but i always also like to say
shirley and doug thank you very much for
your submissions tonight on behalf
surely on behalf of chadron and doug
thank you on behalf of community board
that's right
pleasure thank you
any questions of when he
thank you for that um yeah i thought it
was good for wendy to go first because
she did send a really good we report
through so i thought that probably
covered off a few things um as she said
it's it's been fairly busy with um zoom
meetings and that but um so the usual
council meetings and briefings and in
that but um we also were fortunate
enough to have a hiatus week between
easter and
anzac and of course sprinkle a bit of
covet in there and it's not made for the
most productive time um but you know
that's life um just a couple of things i
guess i'll talk about um on the 13th of
april we had the arahati um
meeting which is
the one the reason i bring this up
regularly actually is because for
instance in our ltp and annual plant
submissions we talk about riparian
planting and whatnot and that would most
likely be the vehicle that that we will
get more planting done but right now
they're working on a branch of the cam
that runs through to a heavy in a loop
but that's
it's proceeding i'll say proceeding
slowly but um
we're getting there and um
it's just really good to
you know
be getting some some plants on the
ground and and um getting the work done
if however slowly
on the
24th of april and 25th i too attended
the oxford or rather first the ohoka
anzac ceremony and on the 24th
and then
oxford and westierton on anzac day
itself and you know it really is it's um
a real honor and a pleasure to go to
those ceremonies and lay the wreaths on
behalf of those who have served and
fallen
um i always get a lump in my throat
whenever i go to those things every
single one of them
um
and they all have their own flavor
their own feel to them and um
yeah they're
moving right along but yeah they were
even though they were short and sweet
this year they were still um
it was great that we're actually able to
have them in person so i was
appreciative of that
um
a couple interesting things
um for you guys the unr meet that sorry
utilities and roading meeting on the
26th
they had a
report on the flood events that we've
just had and they logged
598 service requests
just over over the recent flood events
and that's 75 percent of our usual
annual amount we usually get about 800
of those and they got 598
just for that
and then with the high ground water and
saturated catchments resulting in in
further service requests logged they've
ended up in the last 12 months with 1500
service requests
which is like
more than you know
well almost double the um the usual
annual amount so they are um
a bit stretched at the moment to say the
least but getting through it
obviously we've had some we've
had some real events that's for sure
um on the also that evening there was
the um youth council meeting
and um sorry why mccary youth council
two different things
and we had um as our guest speaker
hillary cooper who is this year's
current weimac career youth mp who is
working with matt ducey this year and
she's got a really interesting project
going on for um youth driver licensing
because um yeah it's kind of a
convoluted process and it's kind of
confusing for for youth who are trying
to traverse that so i think the things
that she's talking about um
are
make a really worthy project and i'll be
interested to see where she gets um with
that
um
on the 27th we had the alcohol and drug
harm prevention steering group meeting
that i'm part of and we had the as a
guest to that we had the field
intelligence officer for the waimakariri
police
and um just amongst some of the things
we discussed it was interesting that to
note that
um
the
drug problem in the area particularly
meth it's it's not growing or shrinking
it's just staying consistent
there's evidence of of it in wastewater
and that but it's just it's not really
sort of changing but and um
which i guess is good that it's not
growing
and it's also not
looking like it's um
originating from here but
you know it's it's still the dry
meth is still the biggest driver of
adult crime so it's it's something that
you know we really want to keep an eye
out on but
um
and on the second of may i went to matt
ducey's public meeting down at
mandeville regarding the north
canterbury connectivity issues
um that was quite a good meeting
actually he had um representatives there
from spark naval and a murinet just
talking about sort of where they were at
with their various initiatives and that
and um
i suppose a couple things of note were
that
uh well
amirinette explained
sort of who they were where they're
coming from and about the rollout and
how you um you know if you're in the
area um how you might connect or or
perhaps um future
ability to connect but i would just say
if any if you know anybody that's
interested in looking into that that
falls in in the
area that they're looking to roll new
fiber installation out to get in touch
with the marionette and if you're not in
there get in touch with them anyway
because you might be able to actually
make something happen
um and
um graham from spark
was interesting as well he
um just just a few things he said that
spark was um
they were moving towers into
tower companies so that they can
increase investment opportunities and
attract some more funding so they're
actually
moving their assets around
in a way that they can actually
raise some capital and hopefully
invest more in the infrastructure we
desperately need
um one of the interesting things that he
said was that
current government policy settings are
for state um highway mobile black spot
areas so so whenever they've rolled out
um chain ruled out new cell phone towers
and that to cover the black spots and
the recent program that they've just
mostly completed um that was
for
state highway mobile black spot areas
not council roads so like say you're out
the back of airwell forest
you're not on a state highway
too bad which is not really what we
wanted to hear but
we just need to keep knocking on that
door
and another interesting thing they were
saying that they
are looking to upgrade to 4g
and
so if for those people that are out in
in really rural areas that have
horrific cell phone coverage um you know
we i'm sure you've all been out in areas
and farms and that where it just isn't
um
you'd have to stand on one leg with your
tongue hanging out the wind blowing the
right direction to get coverage
when they update that upgrade that to 4g
um it'll be 4g only coverage so if
you've got an old cell phone you'll
probably need to upgrade because the
people that have a 4g phone like a a
newer cell phone they will actually get
a raised level of service they will
actually get better
connection but if those that are on
older cell phones will need to upgrade
so it's kind of good to know because
they don't really sort of say that in
the line between the lines so
um and the other the other improvement
that they are looking to get which this
is spark
which um two degrees and vodafone
already have is wi-fi calling so if
you're at home you have stink internet
or rather you have stink cell phone
reception but you have okay internet
somehow by some miracle um you can
actually get your cell phone calls
through your wi-fi which i don't know
about you guys but that would help me
immensely but unfortunately i'm on spark
so we have to wait because they don't
know actually when that's going to
happen just yet
but yeah it was it was a really
interesting um
conversation with
the the locals and the
um
those in the industry so um i really
appreciated that matt pulled all those
guys together and i think all of the um
residents that came to that also did and
i took the opportunity to reiterate that
that is something that i personally
believe that um better cell fund
reception better productivity in
internet is
really important for productivity
sustainability and resilience we need it
out in our rural areas and it's not
enough to just say that you have to live
in an urban um dense area to to
get those things because look at the
backbone of our economy is what
the rural zone
so
um
anyway um moving right along from that
soapbox uh council meeting yesterday
of interest there is the butcher's road
culvert down this way in ohoka um is to
be fixed and it'll probably be about
september
they're ordering looking to order
probably a box culvert
um
for that and it's it will take that long
for them to manufacture it and get it
there but we probably wouldn't be able
to do any fixing of it over the winter
anyway because in stream um works you've
got to do them at the right time of
of year whenever rivers are running high
and whatnot so um
but i would just like to extend a
bouquet again to joanne
um our roofing manager
for her response to um
the resident's request that reached out
to me and asked that the butcher's road
culver be opened foot traffic in cycles
um
she
not only listened spoke to him and
liaised with us but she actually made it
happen so i'm
thrilled with that it's not you know it
doesn't have the road open but at least
people can ride a bike safely through or
or walk their dog or whatever so
um that's actually a good outcome in the
meantime um from where i'm sitting so
um
and yeah and just as wendy said annual
plan hearings today and tomorrow
and thank you doug and shirley for
coming and speaking to us
are there any questions ladies and
gentlemen
okay then i'm sure you've heard enough
of my voice for the night then
sorry i missed some of it
my battery ran flat
oh no
you probably knew it all anyway
so i just i just had to rush around and
sort things out
psychology
my reception's cut out a couple times
while i've been sitting here tonight too
so i've missed a couple things i think
hence my interest in the
telecommunications discussion
and i have fiber
right thank you all
we will move on to
consultation projects around
no we don't okay
thank you for the reports then
cultural predictation projects nil
board from the update
broad discretionary grant at four
thousand and eleven dollars
general landscaping
at three hundred
no media items no questions
understanding orders
virgin general business understanding
orders none
the next meeting will be on wednesday
the 8th of june 2022 at 7 p.m
i'm through you doug just to rem
to advise that we are now going back to
physical meetings
um so the next meeting will actually
be as advertised i will i can't remember
where we're going but i will let members
know
i don't know whether we can cope with it
zero
did you wave your hands there
no
um
we're a bit out with our time surely
so i'll close the meeting
and we can move into workshop for
members forum if you wish